[Applaudissements]
alors qu'ici a déjà entendu parler de la
crypto monnaie bitcoin kiev qui
possèdent des bitcoins et bien si
seulement vous aviez investi 1000 euros
en bitcoin il ya six ans vous seriez
aujourd'hui millionnaire
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il ya encore
plein de crypto monnaie qui pourrait
vous rendre millionnaire
la preuve il ya quelques mois à peine
un entrepreneur a levé plus de 30
millions de dollars
en trente secondes avec la vente d'une
nouvelle crypte monnaie et des dizaines
de projets depuis ont levé plusieurs
centaines de millions de dollars en
l'espace de quelques jours voire même de
quelques heures pour certains ces
projets qui ne relèvent souvent que
d'une idée préliminaire ou d'un
prototype dans le meilleur des cas se
financent donc avec la vente de
nouvelles crypto monnaie des monnaie
virtuelle utilisée pour financer des
projets qui sont tout aussi virtuel mais
alors qu'est ce qui pousse les gens à
investir tous ces millions dans ses
projets et bien la spéculation tout
simplement
c'est à dire la volonté d'acheter
quelque chose dans l'espoir de pouvoir
le revendre plus cher par la suite alors
cela me semble peut-être fou et pourtant
c'est ce qui se passe tous les jours
dans le monde de la finance
ce désir de s'enrichir en investissant
dans des projets dont la valeur devient
alors complètement déconnectée de
l'économie réelle
c'est une dynamique que l'on observe
depuis des centaines d'années
rappelez-vous au xviie siècle avec la
crise des tulipes aux pays bas la crise
de 1929 aux états unis ou encore la
crise de 2008
ces crises présentent toutes des
dynamiques qui se répète de façon
cyclique
elle commence par une phase de
croissance et d'accumulation suivi par
une période de spéculations
et puis enfin d'un effondrement et
chacune de ces crises vous avez prendre
conscience de la fragilité de notre
système économique et de l'incapacité de
nos institutions financières
de faire face à ces crises et puis en
2008 quelque chose a changé
face à un effondrement de notre économie
mondiale un système alternatif est né un
système fondé sur des monnaies
virtuelles qui ne sont contrôlés ni par
un état ni par une banque centrale
mais uniquement par un protocole
informatique
bienvenue dans le monde décrypte monnaie
mais pour bien comprendre ce nouveau
monde
il faut d'abord comprendre le
fonctionnement de la monnaie les
premières monnaies étaient des
ressources telles que le sel les pierres
précieuses les métaux ou le cacao qui
avait une valeur en elle même et puis
pour faciliter les échanges la monnaie
se transforme en un instrument financier
dont la valeur est déterminée par des
autorités de confiance tels que les
banques ou les états qui en garantissent
la valeur dans le temps
sauf que puisque les banques sont
autorisées à prêter plus d'argent
qu'elles ne possèdent elles font la
possibilité de créer de la monnaie
même si de façon théorique mans
temporaire en offrant des prêts à
découvert et c'est là un des facteurs
principaux qui ont porté à la crise
financière de 2008 qui nous a fait pas
mal de confiance dans nos institutions
financières et c'est précisément cette
perte de confiance qui a motivé la
création de beats grubb une monnaie
virtuelle qui peut être échangée entre
pairs sans passer par aucune banque
n'est autre institution financière créée
par un individu qui se cache sous le
pseudonyme de satoshi nakamoto bitcoin
est un système de payement décentralisée
qui a pour vocation de remplacer le rôle
des institutions financières c'est donc
une monnaie virtuelle ou une crypto
monnaie dont la valeur ne dépend d'aucun
opérateurs de confiance pour son
fonctionnement
elle s'appuie sur une nouvelle
technologie la blogueuse qui élimine
complètement la notion de confiance et
qui la remplace par un système fondé sur
la preuve c'est donc ce qu'on appelle en
systèmes tros place puisque tant que
vous faites confiance à la technologie
sous-jacente
vous n'avez besoin de faire confiance à
personne bitcoin se présente alors comme
une technologie de rupture qui porterait
à une véritable mutation de l'ordre
économique et sociale de notre société
une innovation qui nous permettrait
peut-être de sortir de ces cycles
récurrents d'accumulation et de crise et
de nous diriger vers une société plus
ouverte et des intermédiaires
mais ces promesses se sont elles
vraiment réalisé pour l'instant pas
vraiment et la raison c'est que par sa
nature même
bitcoin à recréer les mêmes logiques de
marché attirant aussi les mêmes acteurs
et reproduisant les mêmes dynamiques
d'accumulation et de spéculations que
l'on retrouve dans le monde de la
finance traditionnelle est donc encore
une fois l'histoire se répète croissance
et accumulation spéculation et puis un
jour la crise mais nous n'en sommes pas
encore là
bitcoin est aujourd'hui en pleine phase
d'expansion avec une valeur de plus de
7000 euros
c'est trois fois plus de sa valeur il ya
six mois pareil pour était rien une
autre crypto monnaie dont la valeur est
passée de 20 euros à plus de 200 euros
en l'espace de quelques mois et de
nouvelles applications apparaissent tous
les jours sur les blocs chain chacune
avec sa crypte de monet associés car si
jusqu'à présent seules les banques
pouvaient créer de la monnaie
désormais avec la bloque chain chacun
peut créer sa propre crypto monnaie les
opportunités sont infinies et pourtant
jusqu'à présent la plupart de ses
cryptes monnaie ne sont utilisés qu'à
des fins de spéculation
les gens ne les achète que parce qu'ils
espèrent pouvoir les vendre plus tard
sur le marché à un prix plus élevé cela
ne vous rappelle rien la crise de 2008
bien sûr sauf que cette fois ci les
dynamiques sont encore plus exacerbée
les gens utilisent aujourd'hui des
crypto monnaies telles que bitcoin ou et
terre pour investir dans de nouvelles
crypto monnaie cela fait augmenter la
demande et donc la valeur des bitcoins d
et r ce qui permet aux gens de
réinvestir cet argent dans de nouvelles
crypto monnaie dont la valeur est encore
assez faible et cela fait alors
augmenter la demande et la valeur de ces
nouvelles crypte monnaie ce qui va donc
générer encore une nouvelle ville de
spéculation et donc encore une fois
l'histoire se répète
et je le répète encore une fois
croissance accumulation spéculation et
puis un jour la crise mais attention il
ne faut pas baisser les bras
nous sommes actuellement dans une phase
de hype avec des crypto monnaie dont la
valeur est complètement déconnectée de
l'économie réelle mais il ne faut pas
pour cela oublier ni ignorer le vrai
potentiel de cette technologie
la blocs chine est une innovation
radicale qui nous offre de nouvelles
opportunités
et si cette technologie est aujourd'hui
utilisée essentiellement à des fins de
spéculation la blue jays nous permet
aussi de créer de nouveaux modèles
économiques avec des systèmes plus
ouvert et collaboratif et décentralisé
et pour cela il est important que des
gens comme nous
comme vous s'intéresse cette nouvelle
technologie et en explore les vraies
potentialités
il faut s'y mettre dès maintenant pour
ne pas louper le train mais surtout nous
devons accompagner cette innovation avec
un nouvel état d'esprit une révolution
culturelle dans nos modes de vie et de
pensée qui puisse transformer cette
innovation en progrès et c'est ainsi que
nous pourrons alors sortir de ces cycles
récurrents d'accumulation et de crise et
ne dirigeait alors vers une société
nouvelle une société axée sur les
valeurs de partage et collaboration
merci
[Applaudissements]